SESSION.
ASSEMBLY ONE RUBIO NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
ACOSTA [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
PEROT [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
GABRIELLE [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
GEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLEY [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
HONG [inaudible]
FRASER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
IN ORDER GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HARPER [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
WE KNOW [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MAYES [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI AREA [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RADIUS [inaudible]
REEBOK'S YES [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO [inaudible]
STEINORTH [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
T. [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WEBER.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THIS WEEK ON JULY FOURTH.
WE WILL CELEBRATE INDEPENDENCE
DAY.
ON THIS DAY IN SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
SIX THE THIRTEEN COLONIES
DECLARED THEIR INDEPENDENCE FROM
ENGLAND AND KING GEORGE THE
THIRD.
IT WAS THE BIRTH OF OUR NATION.
BACK THEN.
INFORMATION AND PEOPLE TRAVEL AT
A MUCH SLOWER PACE.
THE WORLD SEEMED VAST.
JUST DIFFERENT TRIGO IN NINETEEN
FOURTEEN IT TOOK MONTHS BEFORE
PEOPLE IN PARTS OF AMERICA KNEW.
THAT WORLD WAR ONE HAD BEGUN IN
EUROPE.
TODAY PEOPLE TRAVEL AND MOVE AT
A SPEED UNIMAGINED EVEN ONE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
INFORMATION IS SHARED ALMOST
INSTANTANEOUSLY ON THE WORLDWIDE
WEB.
WE ARE NOW INTERCONNECTED WITH
MORE COUNTRIES CULTURES AND
PEOPLE THAN EVER BEFORE.
EVEN MORE ESSENTIALLY.
WE LIVE NOW WITH THE GROWING
AWARENESS THAT THE WELL BEING OF
HUMANITY IS NOT SEPARATE.
FROM THE HEALTH OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE EARTH
ITSELF. FOR TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO YEARS WE HAVE JOYFULLY
CELEBRATED INDEPENDENCE DAY.
AS WE EMBRACE THIS TIME IN WHICH
WE ARE NOW LIVING.
THAT IS ALL EMBRACED THE REALITY
OF OUR GLOBAL INTERDEPENDENCE.
ALL LIFE IS INTERWOVEN.
IN THE LIVING FABRIC OF THIS ONE
WORLD THAT WE SHARE.
NOW MORE MEAN THEM.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER LEVINE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
IRAQ.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO BEARS A JUNE SEVENTH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT NINE AM ON WILL
COVER MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE
THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING SHE
FORBID AWESOME WASN'T THE
DESPERATE FOR KATHLEEN LOS
READING.
THE RULES CALLS HIM REMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN WITH EQUAL PROBABLY
SIMPLY MOTION CARRY TIME NONE OF
IBM MISTER CALDERON MOVES.
AND MR MAIENSCHEIN SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE OF
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BIGELOW AND PEROT.
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
WHEN EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AND
AL.
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
FLOOR TODAY THEIR GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED AT THEIR DESKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT.
FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN A MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I MOVED TO THE SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULES SIXTY THREE IN NINETY SIX
TO WITHDRAW SB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
AND S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY TWO FROM
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING. TO TAKE UP
THE BILL'S TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
MISS WALDRON FOR WHAT PURPOSE WE
OPPOSE THAT MOTION.
MISS WALDRON WITH HOLES MEMBERS
THIS IS GOING TO BE A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MISTER CALDERON MOVES A
SECOND BY MISTER BONTA.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION THIS IS
A PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
I. THOUGH.
AND MISS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR
NO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
MS WALTERS ASKING FOR NOVA TAKES
FORTY ONE ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MEMBERS [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
I SEE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MISTER.
CALDERON YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
TO TAKE UP AG ARE FORTY SIX
WITHOUT REFERENCE. TO TO
COMMITTEE OR FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADOPTION.
AND MISS WALDRON TOUGH I OPPOSE
THAT MOTION.
MISS WALDRON AGAIN WITH HOLDS
UNANIMOUS CONSENT AS A RULE
SUSPENSION MISTER CALDERON MOVES
MISTER BONTA SECONDS.
THAT THE RULES BE SUSPENDED THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER
CALDERON TASK FOR NIVEAU.
AND MISS WALDRON AND NO.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
AND WALDRON IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE.
RECEIVE YOUR VOTE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS.
NINETEEN THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED
[inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM NINETY ONE S.
B. NINE TWENTY NINE MCGUIRE IN
ITEM ONE TO S. B.. TWELVE THIRTY
TWO BRADFORD FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALSO AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM EIGHTY NINE S. B.
EIGHT SIXTEEN SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
I MOVED TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY NINE NINETY SIX TO
WITHDRAW S. B. NINE A ONE DOT
FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN. TO TAKE
UP THE BILL TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS IN
THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MISS FRIEDMAN WHEN YOU HAVE A
VERY SPECIAL GUEST ON THE FLOOR
TODAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR DESK.
HI MEMBERS MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU SO MUCH I'M JUST APPY TO
HAVE MY DAUGHTER RACHEL WOULD
MEAN TO TURN FIVE TWO WEEKS AGO
.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR TO TO
MR ALLEN MISTER ALLEN YOU HAVE A
VIP ON THE FLOOR.
YES I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE --
CHARLOTTE MY DAUGHTER SHE'S --
IN YOUR SUMMER BREAKS IF YOU
WANNA COME ON DOWN AND SEE WHAT
DAD DOES ON LEGISLATIVE FLOOR
[inaudible]
CHARLOTTE ALLEN
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
IT SAYS SECOND READING
[inaudible]
CORKERY.
SENATE BILL 495-107-91018
TWO WITH AMENDMENTS ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WITH A MEMBERS FOR THE TO
THE MERITS THEN SEVENTY TWO WITH
A MINUTES. THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE
THE MINUTES FIFTEEN AWAY WITH
MANY SMALL FORTY NINE WITH HIM
IT'S A TWENTY EIGHT WITH MINUTES
WILL THIRTEEN WITH A MINUTES.
A NINETY TWO WITH MEMBERS
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN WITH A
MINUTES EIGHT NINETY NINE WITH
MEMBERS NINE SEVENTEEN TO MANAGE
A TWENTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
ONE FORTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS.
TO THE FOURTEEN THIRTY FOR THE
MEMBERS FORTY FIFTY ONE OF THE
METHODS FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
MINUTES FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO AMEND
ITS TWELVE SIXTY PERMITS ONCE
EVERY FIVE MINUTES. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH A MEMBERS AND
SENATE BILL TEN FORTY FIVE
MINUTES.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
CITIES MISTER TANG WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE S. B..
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS SB.
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE CLERK READ.
SUITABLE A FIFTY SEVEN BY THE
COMMITTEES THAT COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW AND ACT
LIKE A PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES IN
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PARA
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MR KING YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MUCH SPEAKER S. B.
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN IS OUR TRAILER
BILL REGARDING IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES UNDER CURRENT LAW.
MOST OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES GO THROUGH ORIENTATION
PROCESS.
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROVIDERS ARE EMPLOYEES OF LOCAL
PUBLIC AUTHORITY ORGANIZATIONS
SO THESE REQUIREMENTS DO NOT
CURRENTLY APPLY TO THEM.
THE TRAILER BILL A PILOT THIS
REQUIREMENT FOR AYE EACH S. AS
PROVIDERS IN THREE COUNTIES
ORANGE MERCED IN LOS ANGELES AND
TOLD. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THEY WISH TING MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION NASEBY EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE.
THAT AYE AITCHISON SERVICE
PROVIDER ORIENTATIONS INCLUDE A
SESSION FOR A PRESENTATION BY
THE UNION.
THIS WOULD NOT BE SUCH A BAD
THING EXCEPT THAT CURRENT STATE
LAW PROHIBITS ANY ANTI LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS FROM HAVING ACCESS
TO THE SAME ORIENTATIONS.
I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
EMPLOYEES ABILITY TO FREELY
ASSOCIATE WITH THE UNION OF
THEIR CHOICE TO REPRESENT THEM
BUT I ALSO SUPPORTER OF THE IDEA
THAT EMPLOYEES CAN CHOOSE TO NOT
BE REPRESENTATIVE THEY VIEW.
THAT REPRESENTATION IS NOT BEING
IN THEIR BEST INTEREST I THINK
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO ALL OF THE INFORMATION WHEN
MAKING THIS IMPORTANT DECISION
AND I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE BUDGET ITEM
MISTER TING YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH.
THANK YOU IT SPEAKER AGAIN THIS
IS JUST A PILOT IN THREE
COUNTIES ORANGE MERCED LOS
ANGELES AND TOLD. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE I THINK IT'S PERFECTLY --
MAKES SENSE TO PILOT IN THE
THREE COUNTY SEE HOW WE DO A
COMEBACK WITH DATA TO LOOK AT
HOW THIS MIGHT IMPACT THE REST
THE STATE RESPECT YES RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHANG WITH
VACLAV LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THERE IS ARE TO
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY VOTE EYES
[inaudible]
FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE'S.
MEMBERS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THIS IS SB. EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO SP EIGHT SEVEN TWO CORKERY.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY TWO BY
THE COMMITTEEON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACCOLADE THAT TAXATION
MAKING APPROPRIATION AIRPORT TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PARA
RELATE TO THE BUDGET.
MR TAKE A MAKE IT OPEN.
THANK YOU S. B. EIGHT SEVEN TWO
A MAN'S A. B. EIGHTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH WE PROVED ON
THURSDAY.
THERE WAS ARE CLARIFICATION ON
THE DEFINITION OF CANNABIS
PRODUCTS OF THIS WAS BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTION BY THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN DEFEATING COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO.
AND SO WE ARE MAKING THIS A ONE
MODIFICATION IN S. B. EIGHT
SEVEN TWO RESPECT FOR HOUSE
RIGHT.
THEY WISH TAKE MISTER OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
JUST A COMMONSENSE CLEAN UP TO
THE BILL THAT PASSED
OVERWHELMINGLY OUT OF THIS
CHAMBER.
LAST WEEK --
THAT CLARIFIES THAT THE EXISTING
TAXES ON CANNABIS CONSOLE
CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED ARJUN AYE
VOTE.
THANK MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
OUR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT OF NO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIE THAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP AJ ARE. FORTY SIX BY
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THIS IS A
CHAIR FORTY SIX CORPORATE READ.
SO WE JOINT RESOLUTION FORTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ANOTHER'S RELATIVES
FEDERAL ZERO TOLERANCE ABOUT
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AJ ARE FORTY SIX IS VERY SIMPLE
AND ASK THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO RETHINK THEIR ZERO TOLERANCE
POLICY.
WHICH HAS LED TO FAMILY
SEPARATION CHILD DETENTION AND
NOW THE PROMISE A PROLONGED
FAMILY DETENTION AT OUR BORDER.
I'M DEEPLY SADDENED THAT THIS
RESOLUTION IS EVEN NECESSARY AND
FRUSTRATED THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUOUSLY FIGHT OUR PRESIDENT
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION. TO
SIMPLY ACT IN A HUMANE MANNER.
WHAT WE'VE WITNESSED IN RECENT
MONTHS?
IT'S VERY PERSONAL TO MANY OF
US.
BUT IT REALLY SHOULD BE
PERSONAL.
TO ALMOST ALL OF US.
BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS NEARLY ALL
OF OUR ANCESTORS AT ONE POINT
WHERE IMMIGRANTS.
LET'S HEAR NATIVE AMERICAN OR
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
YOUR ANCESTORS CHOSE TO COME
HERE.
AND MANY TIMES.
THE STORY WASN'T ALWAYS SO
CLEAN.
I THINK THOSE OF US WHOSE
ANCESTORS CAME MOST RECENTLY.
MIGHT UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITY
OF THEIR STORIES IN A DIFFERENT
WAY.
I KNOW PERSONALLY.
HOW MY FATHER CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY?
AND I'M LIKE SO MANY OF THE
REFUGEES THAT ARE COMING TODAY
HE DIDN'T COME.
TRYING TO SAVE HIS LIFE.
HE CAME FOR A BETTER LIFE.
BUT I'LL ALSO KNOW IS COMPLEX HE
CAME RIGHT WHEN THE BRASS SADDLE
PROGRAM WAS ENDING.
THERE WAS NO REELS LINE TO STAND
DOWN.
BUT WHAT THE WE CAN A NOD.
AND GROWERS WHO DESPERATELY
NEEDED CHEAP LABOR.
FOLKS COULD CROSS THE BORDER
HERE TO WORK [inaudible]
WAS COMPLICATED.
THE LEGALITY OF IT IS
COMPLICATED.
AND EVEN TODAY WE TRY TO CLEAN
UP THE WAY IN WHICH HE GOT HERE.
PICKED OUR FOOD.
PACKED OUR FOOD.
STARTED A BUSINESS PAID TAXES
SEND HIS KIDS TO COLLEGE.
INSTILL STRUGGLES TO TRY TO
BECOME A CITIZEN.
OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN COMPLEX.
BUT SO MANY OF US WHO KNOW THOSE
STORIES OF OUR PARENTS OR
GRANDPARENTS OR MAYBE OURSELVES.
SEE WHAT'S HAPPENED AT THE
BORDER TODAY AND REALIZE THAT
COULD SO EASILY BE US.
I'M HONEST ABOUT MY FAMILY.
WHO'VE COME FROM MEXICO.
ALL WITH DIFFERENT STATUS.
SOME CAME ON A VISA THAT THEY
OVERSTATED.
SOME SIMPLY CAME HERE WITHOUT
ANY DOCUMENTATION.
SOME CAME IN WHAT THEY'RE
CALLING CHAIN MIGRATION AND
MARRIED SOMEBODY.
BUT NONE OF THEM HAD A FORMAL
PASSED.
A LEGAL PATH.
NOT OF A MORE FACING ATROCITIES
OF SOME OF THE PEOPLE COMING
TODAY FROM THESE COUNTRIES WHERE
THERE TED.
WEEKLY FLEEING FOR THEIR LIFE.
MOST OF MY RELATIVES DIDN'T COME
WITH CHILDREN THAT THEY HAD TO
WORRY ABOUT BEING SEPARATED FROM
THEY CAME HERE AND HAD CHILDREN.
SO WHAT I SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING
TODAY I'D BE A HYPOCRITE. TO NOT
STAND UP.
AND SAY HOW WRONG IT IS.
WHEN WE SEE CHILDREN CRYING FOR
THEIR PARENTS AND PARENTS CRYING
FOR THEIR CHILDREN?
WHEN WE SEE THE POSSIBILITY
[inaudible]
A FAMILIES.
LIVING TOGETHER INCARCERATED.
FOR GOD KNOWS HOW LONG.
WE HAVE TO THINK THAT WE'RE A
BETTER COUNTRY THAN NOT.
BECAUSE NO MATTER IF YOU KNOW
YOUR IMMIGRANT HISTORY. FOR THE
MAJORITY OF US WHO.
WHO SOMEHOW HAVE AN IMMIGRANT
HISTORY?
OR WHETHER YOU SIMPLY LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA THERE IS ONE THING
THAT'S CLEAR.
WE HAVE ALL BENEFITED FROM THE
HARD WORK.
OF THOSE WHO CAME HERE WITHOUT
DOCUMENTATION.
IT'S NOT A POPULAR THING TO SEE
OR TALK ABOUT.
BUT WE'VE HAD OUR CHILDREN
TAKING CARE OF WE HAD OUR
BATHROOMS CLEANED.
WE HAD OUR LANDSCAPED DONE.
WE HAD OUR TABLES BUST OUR FOOD
COOKED.
AN EVEN IF YOU WANT TO DENY ANY
OF THOSE THINGS IF YOU'VE NEVER
BEEN EATEN OUT AT A RESTAURANT
OR EATING OUT AT A RESTAURANT OR
IN A HOTEL.
HAVING SOMEONE CLEAN UP AFTER
YOU I GUARANTEE YOU THIS.
YOU HAVEN'T EATEN FOOD.
THAT WAS PICKED [inaudible]
IMPACT BY SOMEBODY WHO'S HERE
ILLEGALLY.
AND IT WAS ALWAYS IN OUR BEST
INTERESTS TO TURN A BLIND EYE
BUT THESE ARE PEOPLE.
SO WE CAN'T ON ONE HAND.
HAVE THE FRUITS OF THE LABOR OF
HARD WORKING FOLKS IN THE STATE.
AND ON THE OTHER HAND LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT OUR BORDER.
THAT IT JUSTIFIES HUMANITY AND
NOT STAND UP AND SAY.
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH US
THIRTY SECONDS WHAT WE CAN'T
HAVE AN OPEN BORDER.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
WE DO HAVE TO HAVE RULES.
BUT THOSE RULES CAN TREAT PEOPLE
IN A MORE HUMANE WAY.
AND OUR IMMIGRATION POLICIES CAN
BE FIXED WE NEED COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
WE NEED TO TREAT PEOPLE LIKE
PEOPLE.
NOT ANIMALS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
DOCUMENTS GONZALEZ FLETCHER MS
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RISE TODAY AND SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THE DAY ARE.
FORTY SIX I WAS SIXTH WHEN I WAS
DEPORTED. TO WHAT IS MEXICO.
I DO ME NO QUIET IS IS ONE OF
THE MOST DANGEROUS CITIES IN THE
WORLD.
MY FATHER HAD BEEN PART OF THE
BETH HAD A PROGRAM.
WHEN IT ENDED HE CONTINUED TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY WITH US TO
WORK AND TO KEEP US SAFE?
BUT DAVID DETAINED MY DAD.
HE HAD BEEN WORKING IN
CONSTRUCTION.
WE WERE UP IN A PARK IN WINNIE
TEXAS.
AND I REMEMBER MEN IN UNIFORM.
TALKING WITH HIM.
I WAS SCARED.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GATHER OUR THINGS
BEFORE SENDING US BACK TO WHAT
IT. FOR A LONG TIME.
I DIDN'T THINK I WAS AFFECTED AT
ALL [inaudible]
OR MUCH.
BY THAT EXPERIENCE.
BUT BUILT FRIGHTENING MEMORIES.
CAME RUSHING BACK.
AS I WATCH IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
BEING SEPARATED AND CHILDREN
CAGED.
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN ME.
MY SISTERS AND MY BROTHERS.
I THOUGHT OF MY OWN TWO
CHILDREN.
WHAT IF IT HAD BEEN THEM?
NOT KNOWING.
IF THEY WERE COLD OR HUNGRY.
OR IN DANGER.
AND KNOWING THAT A I WAS UNABLE
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THIS IS HORRIFYING AND THEN
HUMANE.
MY PARENTS ONLY WANTED A BETTER
LIFE FOR US [inaudible]
FORTUNATELY.
WE WERE ABLE TO RETURN.
AND I WAS ABLE TO BECOME A
CITIZEN.
MY LOVE FOR THIS COUNTRY. FOR
THIS GIFT PROMPTED ME TO RUN.
FOR ELECTED OFFICE.
MY FAMILY STORY.
IS THE STORY OF MILLIONS HAVE
COME HERE.
SEEKING FREEDOM AND OPPORTUNITY.
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD HAVE
ALWAYS ADMIRED AMERICA. FOR ITS
COMPASSION AND OPENNESS TO
EMIGRATE TO IMMIGRANTS.
WHO WANT TO WORK HARD?
AND STRIVE FOR THEIR DREAMS
[inaudible]
BUT TODAY.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION HAS
DECIDED TO DEMONIZED IMMIGRANTS.
AND SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
PARENTS FLEEING POVERTY AND
VIOLENCE ELSEWHERE. FOR A BETTER
LIFE ARE NOW SIMPLY JUST TRYING
TO REUNITE WITH THEIR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS.
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN WILL BE
TRAUMATIZED FOR EVER.
THIS IS WRONG.
RESPONSIBLE.
AND GOES AGAINST THE IDEALS.
OF A GREAT NATION BUILT BY
IMMIGRANTS.
LET US REMEMBER WHO WE ARE
[inaudible]
AMERICA.
IS AND ALWAYS.
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A BEACON OF
HOPE.
TO THE WORLD.
LET US RETURN TO BASE IDEAL AND
AND THE ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY
NOW.
ON BEHALF OF MY FAMILY.
THE LATINO CAUCUS.
THE WOMAN'S CAUCUS I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE ON HR.
FORTY SIX THANK YOU MISS RUBIO.
TO GIPSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS AG ARE FORTY SIX AN URGE
NUMBER FORTY FIVE IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION TO MERELY.
CEASE AND DESIST IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE ZERO TOLERANCE FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
THIS CURRENT POLICY IS IN HUMANE
AND ALSO ITS SICKENS ME.
AS A PARENT.
IT SADDENS ME.
THAT CHILDREN ARE STRIPPED AWAY.
FROM THEIR FAMILIES FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
JUST TO SEEK ASYLUM.
I CANNOT IMAGINE.
IF MY OWN CHILDREN.
WAS STRIPPED AWAY FROM ME
[inaudible]
THE SITUATION.
THE SADNESS THE FEAR NOT ONLY
FOR ME BUT ALSO FOR MY CHILDREN
AS WELL. TO PUNISH ARE THESE
CHILDREN.
IS IN HUMANE.
THIS IS NOT AMERICA.
AND IS NOT AMERICAN.
WE DON'T DO THIS WE'RE BETTER
THAN THIS.
AND I WANT TO REMIND --
MOST OF US.
THAT THIS IS NOT NO THIS IS NOT
UNUSUAL.
A EVEN THOUGH I'VE READ ABOUT IT
AND PEOPLE TOLD ME ABOUT IT.
A I CAN ONLY [inaudible]
IMAGINE [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
AFRICANS [inaudible]
WENT THROUGH.
NOT ONLY TO BE PULLED FROM THEIR
COUNTRY.
BUT ALSO BEING PLACED.
IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
AND THEN TO HAVE THE FATHER SOLD
OFF.
AND THE MOTHER SOLD OFF AND ALSO
THE CHILDREN SEPARATED
[inaudible]
THE FEAR.
THAT THAT COSTS AND SOME OF
THESE CHILDREN WILL NEVER.
BE REUNITED.
WITH THEIR BIOLOGICAL PARENTS.
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAS TRANSPIRED
WITH THIS POLICY.
AND SO WHEN I THINK THE WOMAN
FROM SAN DIEGO THOSE WHO'VE
SPOKEN.
AND CERTAINLY ASK A RESOUNDING
AYE VOTE.
ON AJ ARE.
FORTY SIX NAMES GIPSON MISS
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A FEW
WEEKS AGO I STOOD TO SPEAK ON ON
THIS POLICY AND EVEN A FEW WEEKS
AGO WE HAD LITTLE INDICATION.
OF SOME OF THE INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE RECEIVED A WHICH HAS
BEEN SO.
HORRIFYING IN STARTLING THAT I
THINK MANY OF US HAVE HIGH I HAD
A HARD TIME PROCESSING AT US
THIS LAST WEEK AND THERE WERE
THOUSANDS THAT MARCHED ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
BASICALLY SAYING WE NEED TO KEEP
FAMILIES TOGETHER THIS AGAIN IS
NOT A REPUBLICAN DEMOCRAT ISSUE.
THIS IS AN AMERICAN ISSUE.
AND I STAND AGAIN AS A MOTHER IN
AS AN EDUCATOR.
TO TRY TO MAKE SOME SENSE OF THE
US AND I KNOW WE HAVE THE
DADDIES CAUCUS HERE OF COURSE
THE MOMMIES COCCUS AND
GRANDMOTHERS AND GRAHAM.
LAWYERS AND AID IN I JUST THE
PICTURE I PAINTED LEARNING I
HAVE FOUR OF MY OWN GROWING
CHILDREN.
AND I THINK ABOUT ONE OF MY
DAUGHTERS WHO I I FEEL LIKE IT
AND WHEN I'D PUT HER TO SLEEP I
HAD TO CAREFULLY PUT HER IN THE
CRIB.
I HAVE WITH HER BLANKET AFTER
SHE WAS ASLEEP.
OTHERWISE YOU'D WAKE UP IN CRY
AND CRY AND I THINK OF ALL OF
THE WAYS MOTHERS AND FATHERS PUT
THEIR KIDS TO SLEEP. FOR MANY OF
I'M THERE'S A SPECIAL TOY
THERE'S MUSIC OR WHATEVER IT IS
THEY USE AND IT WITHIN A MOMENT
TO BE TORN AWAY FROM YOUR MOTHER
OR FATHER OR CAREGIVER.
AND BE LEFT ALONE WITHOUT ALL OF
WITHOUT THOSE THINGS THAT SU TH
CHILDREN.
I ALSO THINK ABOUT AS KIDS GET
OLDER FOR SO MANY PARENTS RIGHT
HERE IN THIS ROOM --
WHEN THEY GET TO SIXTH GRADE
MANY OF THEM GO OFF TO FOR THE
FIRST TIME TO CAMP?
AND THAT'S A VERY BIG DEAL ON
THEIR BAGS ARE PACKED IN YET
PARENTS ARE NERVOUS IN LETTERS
ARE WRITTEN AND AND TEARS.
AND YET THEY KNOW THEIR PARENTS
ARE COMING BACK IN THE GOING TO
SEE A MENU AND IT'S VERY
EMOTIONAL.
BUT AGAIN TO THINK ABOUT HAVING
A CHILD RIPPED AWAY FROM YOU AND
NOT KNOW IF YOU'RE EVER GOING TO
SEE HIM AGAIN.
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE YOUNG
BABIES WHO DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW
TO SPEAK YET HOPING THAT MAYBE
THEY DID TAKE OF I FINGERPRINT
SO THEY COULD BEREUNITED.
AND THEN AGAIN NOW TO SEE SOME
OF THOSE REUNIONS AND JUST SEE
THE SOBBING AND SOBBING AND NO
THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
SO WHICHEVER WAY YOU FEEL ABOUT
A POLICY WE KNOW THAT THIS
POLICY IS NOT RIGHT AND WE HAVE
TO DIG DEEP AND WE HAVE TO LOOK
WITHIN OUR HEARTS TO SAY THAT WE
CAN DO BETTER.
WE CAN FIX WHAT IS NOT WRONG
URGE YOUR NAME IS QUIRK SILVA.
MR THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
HR FORTY SIX I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND BRING IT FORWARD.
AND FOR ALL THOSE WHO HAVE
SPOKEN WILL SPEAK ON THIS MATTER
TODAY.
AND I ECHO --
THE SENTIMENTS OF THOSE WHO HAVE
SPOKEN THAT WE SHOULD NEVER.
A SEPARATE OUR FAMILIES I'M IN
AND I RISE WHILE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE ARE NOT WHAT I
WOULD HOPE.
I I FEEL HONORED TO BE ABLE TO
STAND ON THIS FLOOR.
AND BILL TO SPEAK ON THIS
RESOLUTION --
ON MY MOTHER'S SIDE --
ALL OF MY AUNTS AND UNCLES AND
MY GRANDPARENTS WE'RE IMMIGRANTS
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
ARE BORN SOMEPLACE ELSE COMING
TO THIS COUNTRY IN HOPES OF
CREATING A BETTER LIFE MY
GRANDMOTHER CAME HERE.
AND SHE ESSENTIALLY AS A
TEENAGER I CLEAN PEOPLE'S
BATHROOMS --
MY AUNTIES --
MANY OF THEM WERE LOW PAID --
HEALTH CARE ASSISTANCE WHO WOULD
BAY SOMEONE OR CHANGED NOW MORE
TEND TO WHATEVER --
THEIR PHYSICAL NEEDS MIGHT BE.
AND WHILE MY FAMILY.
WAS NEVER SPLIT UP BECAUSE OF
DEPORTATION OR IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES UP MY HEART GOES
OUT TO THOSE FAMILIES WHO HAVE
BEEN SEPARATED FROM THEIR
CHILDREN.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T TAKE A ROCKET
SCIENTIST TO KNOW THAT ANY
SEPARATION FROM A CHILD CAN BE
DEVASTATING YOU CAN HAVE
LIFELONG IMPACTS FOR THEM.
I I NOTICED LIKE TO BE SEPARATED
FROM FAMILY THOUGH WHILE IT WAS
NOT RELATED TO IMMIGRATION --
MANY OF YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH I LOST
MY FAMILY AND AT A VERY EARLY
AGE -- WHEN
I WAS SIX YEARS OLD I LOST MY
MOTHER TO CANCER MY FATHER WAS
NOT IN MY LIFE?
AND I GOT SENT [inaudible] TO
FOR AND I DO NOT SEE MOST OF MY
SIBLINGS FOR ALMOST TEN YEARS.
NOW.
FORTUNATE FOR ME THE PERSON WHO
I WAS SENT TO LIVE WITH WAS A
FAMILY MEMBER --
ALBEIT A COUSIN WHO I NEVER MET
TO I SHOWED UP ON HER DOORSTEP
IT WAS STILL DIFFICULT.
IT WAS DIFFICULT AS A CHILD TO
NOT UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR MOTHER
IS NOT COMING BACK TO NOT
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU ARE TO NOT
SEE A FAMILIAR FACE.
AND I SAY THAT AND LIFT THAT UP
TO ASK YOU TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
THOSE IMPACTS MUST BE FOR THE
NINE MONTH THE YEAR OLD FOR THE
ONE YEAR OLD FOR A CHILD OF ANY
AGE.
WHO IS SEPARATED FROM HIS OR HER
MOTHER OR FATHER OR FROM THEIR
SYMBOL FROM THEIR SIBLINGS OR
FROM SIMILAR SURROUNDINGS?
WHAT'S EQUALLY TROUBLING TO ME.
IS THAT WHILE VIS DEVASTATING
POLICIES HAVE BEEN CARRIED OUT
[inaudible]
MANY [inaudible]
COMPANIES HAVE PROFITED
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM THIS WORK IN
JUST A SHORT PETER TIME WE
SHOULD PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON THAT.
UP MANY OF THE PRIVATE PRISONS
I'M HAVE PUT PROFITS OVER WHAT I
WOULD SAY OUR AMERICAN VALUES
AND PRINCIPLES [inaudible]
FAMILY
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALLOWED FOR THIS DIVISIVE IN
CRUEL POLICY TO BECOME A PROFIT.
VENTURE FOR MANY CALIFORNIA HAS
THE SECOND HIGHEST NUMBER OF
IMMIGRATION DETENTION FACILITIES
IN THE COUNTRY.
ALMOST HALF OF THE STATE'S
DETENTION FACILITIES ARE
OPERATED BY PRIVATE COMPANIES TO
DETAIN IMMIGRANT CHILDREN FROM
THROUGHOUT.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY THESE COMPANIES HOUSE
NEARLY 75% OF CALIFORNIA
DETAINEES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND 71% OF DETAINEES NATION
WIDE.
AND IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THESE
PRIVATE PRISON COMPANIES HOUSING
PROFIT OFF OF OVER THREE
THOUSAND IMMIGRANT DETAINEES IN
CALIFORNIA ONE COMPANY ALONE
GTO.
COLLECTED APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY OF TAXPAYER MONEY.
NATIONALLY THE SAME COMPANY
RECEIVES MORE MONEY FOR
IMMIGRATION DETENTION THAN ANY
OTHER ICE CONTRACTOR WHILE THEIR
FACILITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN CITED FOR SOME OF THE
MOST INHUMANE.
PRACTICES ANOTHER COMPANY COURSE
CIVIC THE LARGEST FOR PROFIT
PRISON COMPANY WAS CONTRACTED
FOR JUST UNDER A HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR ICE
RELATED SERVICES AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND THIS YEAR
CALIFORNIA WILL SPEND ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON THESE COMPANIES FOR
VARIOUS SERVICES INCLUDING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA INMATES.
IN AND OUT OF THE STATE.
WE SHOULD STAND UP AS
CALIFORNIANS AS AS AMERICANS AND
SAY.
THAT WE REALLY CARE ABOUT FAMILY
VALUES THAT WE SHOULD FOLLOW THE
TRADITION OF THIS STATE.
WE HAVE INVESTED.
IN MAKING IT EASIER FOR
NATURALIZATION WE SHOULD STAND
UP AND BE LEADERS FOR OUR NATION
AND SAY IT'S TIME TO CREATE.
A RESPONSIBLE IMMIGRATION
PLATFORM THAT CREATES A CITIZEN
OF A PATHWAY TOWARD CITIZENSHIP.
SHE SAID WE VALUE FAMILIES AND
KEEPING THEM TOGETHER NO MATTER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES UPON WHICH
THAT THEY ARRIVE AND WE SHOULD
SAY THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ALLOW PROFIT SYRIAN. TO BENEFIT
THOSE WHO WOULD STAND TO
SEPARATE COMPANIES SEPARATE
CHILDREN SO THAT THEIR COMPANIES
CAN PROFIT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AG ARE.
FORTY SIX THANK YOU MISTER
AUTHORED THIS CARILLO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS WHEN I THINK OF THE WORD
TRADITION.
IT USUALLY IMPLIES SCRIPT
THINKS.
HOLIDAY TRADITIONS CHRISTMAS
THANKSGIVING.
BUT NOT IN THE CASE OF THE
UNITED STATES WHEN IT COMES TO
THE SEPARATION OF FAMILIES THIS
HAS BEEN A TRADITION.
OF THE UNITED STATES A TRADITION
TO SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS DURING SLAVERY A
TRADITION.
A SEPARATE NATIVE AMERICAN
CHILDREN FROM THEIR PARENTS A
TRADITION.
A SEPARATE JAPANESE AMERICAN
KIDS ONE JAPANESE PEOPLE ARE
PUTTING CONCENTRATION CAMPS AND
NOW A TRADITION THAT CONTINUES.
WITH THE SEPARATION OF
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN INTO THIS
COUNTRY BEING PUT IN CAGES.
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS.
THERE IS A BUSINESS TRADITION
BUT THE UNITED STATES HAS.
A BUSINESS OF SLAVERY.
BUSINESS OF BOARDING SCHOOLS FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN CHILDREN.
BUSINESS FOR CONCENTRATION CAMPS
AND NOW A BUSINESS FOR DETENTION
CENTER.
THE DIFFERENCE NOW.
IS THAT THE WORLD IN WHICH WE
LIVE AND IS TRANSPARENT.
WHEN WE GET TO HOLD IT
ACCOUNTABLE?
WE HAVE THE INFORMATION AT OUR
FINGERTIPS.
WE UNDERSTAND AND KNOW THAT THIS
IS NOT NEW.
AND THAT IT WILL CONTINUE.
AND THAT IS UP TO US.
DECIDE WHAT KIND A STATE AND
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY.
WE WANT TO LEAD IN HALF.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
BUT IT IS NOT ENOUGH.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH IN WHAT WE'RE
DOING.
AND HOW WE PLAN ON REUNITING
OVER.
TWO THOUSAND IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
WHO HAVE BEEN SEPARATED FROM
THEIR FAMILIES.%
MANY OF WHOM.
DON'T EVEN SPEAK SPANISH IN FACT
MANY OF WHOM ARE INDIGENOUS. TO
CENTRAL AMERICA.
MANY OF WHOM REQUIRE A
TRANSLATOR FOR THE MESS SO
AMERICAN INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
HEARING IN THE NEWS BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS NEEDED.
I CAME TO THIS COUNTRY WHEN I
WAS.
FIVE MANY OF YOU KNOW MY STORY
I'VE SHARED IT ON THIS FLOOR.
MY FAMILY IN I WORD SEEKING
REFUGE ASYLUM WHICH IS NOT
ILLEGAL IN FACT THAT IS THE VERY
DEFINITION OF THE LAW.
OF THESE UNITED STATES THAT YOU
CAN'T COME AND SEEK ASYLUM THANK
YOU CAN COME AND SEEK REFUGE.
WE LEFT A CIVIL WAR THAT LASTED
TWELVE YEARS.
MANY OF THE CHILDREN THAT ARE
LEAVING CENTRAL AMERICAN
COUNTRIES NOW OUR LATIN AMERICAN
COUNTRIES NOW.
ARE LEAVING.
IN THOSE SAME CONDITIONS.
AND THESE PARENTS THESE MOTHERS
AND FATHERS SIX CHILDREN WHO
WITH EVERYTHING.
TRY TO START ANY LIKE TO HAVE A
CHANCE OF LIFE.
OUR THE BEST TYPE AMERICANS THAT
WE CAN HAVE.
THESE ARE THE TYPE OF PEOPLE
THAT WE SHOULD BE EMBRACING AS A
COUNTRY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING ACROSS OUR
NATION IS A MORAL?
IT'S UNLAWFUL IT'S FUN JUST IT
IS NOT ABOUT FREEDOM.
IT IS NOT ABOUT JUSTICE.
THIS IS ABOUT HEAT IT IS ABOUT
BUSINESS.
IN IS ABOUT PUTTING PEOPLE
BEHIND BARS.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
TO I COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR PUTTING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO
[inaudible]
MR GABRIEL.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF AJ ARE.
FORTY SIX WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION.
SPEAKS DIRECTLY TO THE VALUES OF
COMPASSION AND DECENCY THAT WE
JUST CALIFORNIANS HOLD DEAR.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK AND
RECOGNIZE OUR TOURNEY GENERAL
HAVE YOUR BUT SARAH AND HIS
STAFF FOR THE LITIGATION THEY
HAVE BROUGHT CHALLENGING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S.
IMMORAL AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY AND FOR
THEIR CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
DEFEND OUR CALIFORNIA VALUES.
IN ADDITION TO BEING CONTRARY TO
CALIFORNIA VALUES THE SEPARATION
OF FAMILIES IS ALSO DEEPLY
ANTITHETICAL TO JEWISH VALUES.
AND WITH PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO
READ FROM A LETTER THAT WAS SENT
BY A COALITION OF TWENTY SEVEN
NATIONAL JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS POLICY
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE WRITE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE RECENTLY
EXPANDED ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY
THAT INCLUDES SEPARATING
CHILDREN FROM THEIR MIGRANT
PARENTS WHEN THEY CROSS THE
BORDER.
THIS POLICY UNDERMINES THE
VALUES OF OUR NATION AND
JEOPARDIZES THE SAFETY AND
WELLBEING OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
AS JEWS WE UNDERSTAND THE PLIGHT
OF BEING AN IMMIGRANT FLEEING
VIOLENCE AND OPPRESSION.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE UNITED
STATES IS A NATION OF IMMIGRANTS
AND HOW WE TREAT THE STRANGER
REFLECTS ON THE MORAL VALUES AND
IDEALS OF THIS NATION.
MANY OF THESE MIGRANT FAMILIES
ARE SEEKING ASYLUM IN THE UNITED
STATES TO ESCAPE VIOLENCE IN
CENTRAL AMERICA.
TAKING CHILDREN AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
SUCH PRACTICES INFLICT
UNNECESSARY TRAUMA ON PARENTS
AND CHILDREN.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE ALREADY
SUFFERED TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES.
THIS ADDED TRAUMA IT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH.
PRECLUDING INCREASING THE RISK
OF EARLY DEATH.
OUR JEWISH FAITH DEMANDS US.
DEMANDS OF US CONCERNED FOR THE
STRANGER IN OUR MASTS.
OUR OWN PEOPLE'S HISTORY A
STRANGER'S REMINDS US OF THE
MANY STRUGGLES FACED BY
IMMIGRANTS TODAY AND COMPELS OUR
COMMITMENT TO AN IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT IS COMPASSIONATE AND JOBST.
WE URGE YOU TO IMMEDIATELY
RESCINDED ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY
AND UPHOLD HE VALUES OF FAMILY
UNITY AND JUSTICE ON WHICH OUR
NATION WAS BUILT.
SHORT FOR A COMMUNITY IT WHERE
THERE IS OFTEN DEBATE ON
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES.
THERE IS BROAD CONSENSUS IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY THAT THE ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY IS CONTRARY TO
OUR NATION'S HIGHEST TRADITIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL MS RACE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AJ ARE.
FORTY SIX WHICH CONDEMNS A
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION POLICY OF
SEPARATING FAMILIES THROUGH THE
ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY.
POOR NATION WHICH QUITE
LITERALLY HAS BEEN BUILT ON THE
BACKS OF IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY WITH
IMMIGRANT POPULATIONS HAS BEEN
TUMULTUOUS [inaudible]
AT BEST.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT AGAINST
POLICIES.
CLEARLY AND UNABASHEDLY HAVE NO
REGARD FOR BASIC HUMANITY.
WE CANNOT ALLOW THE TYPE OF IN
HUMANE.
SCARRING TREATMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS TO CONTINUE TO BE
THE REIGNING NARRATIVE OF
AMERICAN HISTORY.
IN THE RECENT COURT RULING WHICH
MANDATED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TO RETURN YOUNGER
CHILDREN TO THEIR PARENTS.
THE JUDGE NOTED THAT PRESENTLY.
MIGRANT CHILDREN ARE NOT EVEN
ACCOUNTED FOR WITH THE SAME
EFFICIENCY INACCURACY.
HAS PROPERTY WOULD BE.
HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY THE
SEPARATION OF CHILDREN FROM
THEIR PARENTS?
WITH VIRTUALLY NO SYSTEM TO
ENSURE KNOWLEDGE OF THEIR
WHEREABOUTS.
WELL YOU CAN TRACK A PIECE OF
FURNITURE YOU'VE ORDERED ON
AMAZON ACROSS BORDERS AND
DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
I AM PLOY YOU MY COLLEAGUES.
WITH THIS GREAT HONOR WE SHARE
REPRESENTING OUR CONSTITUENCIES.
TO THINK CRITICALLY OF WHERE WE
WILL STAND AND WHAT WE WILL BEAT
WHAT WE ARE.
AND WHAT WE ARE DOING IN THIS
MOMENT OF HISTORY.
BECAUSE GENERATIONS DOWN THE
LINE WILL REMEMBER.
THOSE WHO ALLOWED AN ADVOCATE
FOR THE SEPARATION OF CHILDREN
FROM THEIR MOTHERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
AND FOR CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
FIGHT FOR A HOLISTIC REFORM TO
WORK IN HUMANE IMMIGRATION
POLICY [inaudible]
MISTER BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND AS A
PROUD.
CO AUTHOR IN SUPPORT OF AJ ARE.
FORTY SIX ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY
IS INHUMANE IT'S IMMORAL AND IT
DOES NOT REPRESENT WHO WE ARE.
OR WHO SHOULD BE.
FIRST IT SEPARATED CHILDREN.
FROM THEIR PARENTS THEN.
ONLY AFTER NATIONAL.
PUBLIC OUTRAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION BEGAN TO
INCARCERATE FAMILIES TOGETHER.
MEMBERS WE'VE SEEN THIS BEFORE
WE SAW THIS WHEN JAPANESE
AMERICAN FAMILIES.
WHO HAD EVERY RIGHT TO LIVE
FREELY IN OUR COUNTRY?
WERE INCARCERATED DURING WORLD
WAR.
TWO THESE FAMILIES COMING TO OUR
BORDERS ALSO HAVE A RIGHT TO BE
HERE AS THEIR CASES. FOR ASYLUM
ARE BEING HURT.
THIS IS ONLY THE LATEST ACTION
BY THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO
CREATE FEAR.
CHAOS AND DRAMA IN OUR
IMMIGRANT.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN THE NATION [inaudible]
SCHOOL.
AND IS REPREHENSIBLE AND IT MUST
STOP IMMEDIATELY.
AS WE SAW THE HUNDREDS OF
NATIONWIDE MARCHES AND RALLIES
THIS PAST SATURDAY MANY OF YOU
WERE OUT THEM.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS ARE CALLING ON THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. TO
ELIMINATE ITS ZERO TOLERANCE
POLICY AND TO TREAT THOSE
SEEKING SAFETY WITHIN OUR
BORDERS.
WITH DIGNITY AND WITH COMPASSION
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR VOTE
FOR AJ ARE.
FORTY SIX THANK YOU MISTER BONTA
MISTER CHIU.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIRS ARE
MEMBERS AND SANK THOUGHT CALLING
FROM OUTSIDE EAGLE PROGRAMMING
OF THOSE VERY IMPORTANT.
ISSUES ARE ON THE FLOOR --
I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT A
VERY POPULAR TERM.
A CHAIN MIGRATION WAS ACTUALLY
CALLED FAMILY YOUR REUNIFICATION
AND THAT'S HOW I BROUGHT MY WIFE
WILL FORTY TWO TWO YEARS PUTTING
MY TO STATE.
AND OUT ALL OVER THE WEEKEND I
KNOW TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AND I ATTENDED A RALLY IN SAN
JOSE.
I TELL YOU I WAS BROUGH REALLY
REALLY HEARTENED TO SEE SO MANY
YOUNG CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW INFANT.
YOU KNOW TO TO THE ACCOUNT GOES
AROUND THE AYE INITIALLY I FEEL
KIND OF GUILTY BECAUSE I DIDN'T
HAVE MY MY MY THREE YEAR OLD
GRANDCHILDREN.
BUT A FIVE YEAR OLD THREE OH
GRANDCHILDREN WITH ME BUT THEN I
CAN REALLY REALLY MAD.
WHAT KIND OF SOCIETY WE'RE
LOOKING AT?
WELL KIDS YOU KNOW.
A TWO MONTHS OWE YOU DON'T CAMP
BEDDING BLOCK HOUSE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE RALLY.
BUT THEN I REALIZED THE
MASSACHUSETTS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT WE NEED TO DELIVER TO
THOSE.
CAMPS THAT ARE LOCKING PAGERS
THAT THEY ARE NOT ALONE SO I
ENCOURAGE YOU AYE AYE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU
[inaudible]
SURE CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS -- I
READ SOMETHING THIS MORNING --
THAT MADE ME FEEL REAL TERRIBLE
--
EARLIER A SEVEN YEAR OLD GIRL
WAS REUNITED WITH HER MOTHER.
AFTER NEARLY NEARLY TWO MONTHS
IN AN IMMIGRATION.
DETENTION CENTER.
AND THE MOMS MESSAGE TO OTHERS
MOTHERS OTHER MOTHERS WAS THIS
MISTER SPEAKER PERMISSION TO
READ [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IF YOU'RE THINKING OF CLAIMING
ASYLUM.
FIND ANOTHER COUNTRY.
THE LAWS HERE HARSH.
AND PEOPLE DON'T HAVE HEARTS.
THAT TO ME COULDN'T SPEAK.
LESS TO MY MY UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE AN AMERICAN.
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE FROM THE
GREATEST COUNTRY?
IN THE WORLD. TO BE THE GREATEST
COUNTRY WHEN IT COMES TO CARING
AND LOVING.
OTHER PEOPLE AND BEING ABLE TO
SYMPATHIZE WITH THOSE AN
UNFORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCES
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT ARE TRYING
TO FLEE TO SAVE THE LIVES.
AND THE LIVES OF THEIR KIDS AND
I WAS ACTUALLY DISCUSSING THIS
LAST NIGHT WITH MY WIFE --
BECAUSE IT'S TAKEN US AWHILE BUT
WHEN THE SHOWS THAT WE WATCHES
HANDMAID'S TALE AND AND AND
WE'VE WE'VE MADE YOU KNOW WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT.
AT ONE TIME OR ANOTHER ON THIS
FLOOR I'M MAYBE POTENTIAL
PARALLELS BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WAS DIFFICULT WAS THAT IN
THIS LAST EPISODE WAS UP EPISODE
ELEVEN IT'S ENOUGH THICKNESS
WHILE BECAUSE OF HOW HEAVY THE
SHOW IS --
WAS THE MAIN AUTHOR OF THE MAIN
CHARACTER WAS GOT A MOMENT TO
SEE HER CHILD WHO HAD SHE HAD
BEEN TURNED OUT TORN AWAY FROM.
AND IN THAT MOMENT THE CHILD
RECOGNIZE THAT IT WAS HER MOTHER
BUT WAS STILL SCARED OF HER
MOTHER -- IT
SEEMS BUT IT TURNED OUT THAT SHE
WASN'T SCARED OF HER MOTHER.
SHE WAS UPSET WITH HER MOTHER
AND MESSAGE WAS WHY DIDN'T YOU
FIGHT HARDER.
WHY DIDN'T YOU TRY HARDER TO
FIND THE TO COME AFTER ME TO
BRING ME BACK TO YOU INTO BACK
TO DAD AND IT WAS BEYOND HER
CONTROL SHE'S A SLAVE?
IT WAS BEYOND HER CONTROL BUT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE NOW PUTTING
THESE KIDS.
ARE IN THE POSITION THAT WE'RE
PUTTING THEM IN AND WE HAVE TO
THINK LONG AND HARD ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THIS ISN'T ABOUT BEING A
DEMOCRAT THIS ISN'T ABOUT BEING
A REPUBLICAN.
IT'S ABOUT BEING US AS HUMAN
BEINGS AS AMERICANS AND WHAT WE
STAND FOR AND WHAT IS VALUABLE
TO US AND WHETHER WE NOT WE WE
VALUE.
OUR HUMAN VALUES OR NOT AND I
THINK WHAT'S UNFORTUNATE ABOUT A
LOT OF THESE CONVERSATIONS THAT
IT BECOMES ABOUT DEMOCRAT VERSUS
REPUBLICAN.
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT IT SHOULD BE
A BALLOT SHOULD BE ABOUT WHO WE
ARE.
AND WHAT WE BELIEVE IS RIGHT AS
INDIVIDUALS AS PARENTS AS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS SO ON AND
SO FORTH BECAUSE I DON'T CARE IF
SOMEBODY IS A DIFFERENT
POLITICAL IDEOLOGY THAN ME.
I BELIEVE IN SOMEBODY BECAUSE
THEY ARE AMERICAN I KNOW THAT
DEEP DOWN INSIDE OF A WE MAY
DISAGREE POLITICALLY WE STILL
SHARE THE SAME VALUES AS TO WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE AN AMERICAN.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS RESOLUTION
IS ALL ABOUT IT'S ABOUT RESIDENT
IT'S ABOUT SHOWING THAT OUR
VOICE AS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD AS A REALLY
IMPORTANT STATE TO THIS.
NATIONAL ECONOMY AND TO THIS
NATION.
THAT WE DO NOT AGREE WITH THIS
POLICY THAT IS INHUMANE BECAUSE
I'VE HEARD DISTANT RATIONALES US
WHY THIS POLICY EXISTS EITHER
IT'S BECAUSE IT NEEDS TO BE USED
AS LEVERAGE TO TRY TO GET SOME
I'M I'M AT THE OTHER POLITICAL
SIDE TO DO SOMETHING THAT THEY
WANT -- OR
ITS TO DETER OTHER PEOPLE FROM
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
BOTH AT RATIONALIZATIONS ARE IN
HUMANE BOTH ARE WRONG.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE ABOUT.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
NEEDS TO BE A PARTISAN ISSUE
THIS JUST NEEDS TO BE ABOUT AN
ISSUE ARE WERE INDIVIDUALS NOT
LEGISLATORS THAT ARE LABELED
WITH THE DEER ON OUR THAT'S NOT
WHAT'S IMPORTANT.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS THAT WHERE
PEOPLE AND THAT WE CARE ABOUT
OTHER PEOPLE FROM OTHER PLACES
BECAUSE THAT SHOULD MATTER TO US
BECAUSE IT HAS MATTER TO US
THATS WHY WERE THE GREATEST
NATION IN THE WORLD BECAUSE WE
OUR NATION OF IMMIGRANTS AND WE
SHOULD NEVER FORGET THAT.
SO I REALLY THINK THE AUTHOR UP
FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON MISTER
COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION.
AND ON THIS DAY.
I THINK OF THE IMAGE.
SET BY JOHN WINTHROP.
WHO WAS THE LEADER OF THE FLAG
SHIP ARBELLA [inaudible] FOR THE
GROUP OF COLONISTS RICHER
COLORS.
LOOKING TO ESTABLISH THE
MASSACHUSETTS BAY COLONY
[inaudible]
STEAM.
THIRTY AND HE CHALLENGES
COMPANIONS ON THAT SHIP. TO SEE
WHAT THEY WERE DOING AS
ESTABLISHING A CITY SET ON THE
HILL.
THAT THE ENTIRE WORLD WOULD BE
LOOKING AT AND THIS IMAGE OF THE
UNITED STATES IS A CITY SET ON
THE HILL.
IS ONE HAS BEEN FREQUENTLY
PICKED UP.
JOHN KENNEDY SPOKE OF IT WHEN HE
VISIT MASSACHUSETTS DURING HIS
PRESIDENCY.
BUT OFTEN TIMES [inaudible]
RONALD REAGAN.
OR GOVERNOR OR PRESIDENT SPOKE
OF IT.
AND PERMISSION TO READ.
THIS WAS HIS STATEMENTS IN HIS
FINAL ADDRESS TO THE NATION
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
JANUARY ELEVENTH [inaudible]
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE RONALD
REAGAN.
I'VE SPOKEN OF THE SHINING CITY
ALL MY POLITICAL LIFE.
BUT I DON'T NOR FAVOR QUITE
COMMUNICATED WHAT I SAW WHEN I
SAID IT.
BUT IN MY MIND IT WAS A TALL
PROUD CITY.
BUILT ON ROCK STRONG WRITTEN
NOTIONS.
WHEN SWEPT GOD BLESSED AND
TEEMING WITH PEOPLE OF ALL
KINDS?
LIVING IN HARMONY AND PEACE.
A CITY WITH REPORTS THAT HUMMED
WITH COMMERCE AND CREATIVITY.
AND IF THERE HAD TO BE CITY
WALLS.
THE WALLS HAD DOORS AND THE
DOORS WERE OPEN TO ANYONE WITH A
WILLING HEART TO GET HERE.
THAT'S HOW I SAW.
AND I SEE IT'S STILL.
COLLEAGUES HUNDRED HONOR TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS [inaudible]
RESOLUTION.
WE SIT IN THE CHAMBERS.
WITH ABRAHAM LINCOLN A FRONT OF
US WHO ARE GETTYSBURG SPOKE OF
THIS NEW NATION.
THIS NEW NATION WHICH WAS INDEED
NO BUT ALSO WAS A DIFFERENT
NATION.
WORTH FIGHTING TO PRESERVE.
AND I THINK THIS QUESTION WHAT
IS THIS NEW NATION WHAT AS IT'S
UNFOLDING.
WILL REMAIN A CITY ON THE HILL.
REMAINS A VITAL QUESTION ARE DAY
ATTESTED TO BY MANY PRESIDENTS.
AND I'M HONORED TO RISE AND
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY MISTER
EDUARDO GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I AM COMPELLED TO
RISE AS SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
ARE SPOKEN ABOUT THEIR PARENTS.
AND THE ARRIVAL TO THIS COUNTRY.
FOR THE REASONS THAT MANY HAVE
ALREADY.
OUTLINED I'M ENCOURAGED.
BY THE WORDS IN.
THAT HAVE MENTIONED UP BY
EVERYONE HERE ON THE FLOOR TO TO
SHARE A STORY WITH YOU.
I WAS INTERVIEWED BY LOCAL
REPORTERS LAST WEEK TO TALK
ABOUT THE CHILDREN.
AND HOW IT IS JUST.
RESPONSIBLE AND QUITE FRANKLY IN
HUMANE HOW.
THESE CHILDREN ARE BEING
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS.
AND THE CONDITIONS THAT THAT
THEY ARE HAVING TO ADHERE.
TO IN THE QUESTION BEGAN GOING
TOWARDS THE TRAUMATIZING
EXPERIENCE [inaudible]
OF THESE CHILDREN HAVING TO BE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS AND
IT BROUGHT TO MIND.
A MEMORY THAT I HAD TUCKED AWAY
REALLY FAR BACK.
IN MY HEAD.
THE ONE WHERE --
AT EIGHT YEARS OLD.
OUR FATHER IS DETAIN DE HE
OVERSTAYED HIS [inaudible]
VISA.
HAD A BIT ALREADY ESTABLISHED A
FAMILY WORKING.
AS A GARDENER.
AND BEING DETAINED IN BEING --
DEPORTED.
AND THROUGH THE PROCESS BEING
ALLOWED TO BE IN THE DETENTION
CENTER.
KNOW CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I WAS
EIGHT YEARS OLD.
AND SO AYE AYES THE INTERVIEW IS
PROGRESSING I BEGINNING TO THINK
ABOUT [inaudible]
THE FEELING.
THOSE NINE MONTHS.
THAT MY FATHER WAS DETAINED THAT
MY MOTHER WAS CARING FOR MYSELF.
AND HERSELF AS SHE CLEAN THEIR
HOUSES AS A AWAY OF SUSTAINING
THE FAMILY FOR THIS PERIOD OF
TIME.
ON HER OWN AND I REMEMBER THE
FEELING [inaudible]
THAT CHRISTMAS.
OF NOT HAVING OUR FATHER THERE
WAS OF THE FACT I REMEMBER.
THAT DUSTY OLD COUCH WHERE I WAS
SITTING AT GRANDMA'S HOUSE WHILE
ALL THE OTHER CHILDREN WERE
PLAYING AND HAVING A GOOD TIME
WAITING FOR IT. TO BE MIDNIGHT
ON THE TWENTY FOURTH OF
CHRISTMAS AND ME SITTING THERE
IN MY MOM'S ARMS CRYING MY
LUNGS.
NOT KNOWING WHETHER OR NOT THAT
WAS GONNA COME BACK OR NOT NOT.
CARING ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE.
NOT A CHRISTMAS PRESENT.
OR ANY OTHER GIVE.
COULD FILL THAT VOID THAT
FEELING THAT GAP.
THAT WAS THERE AT THAT MOMENT
NOT KNOWING IF.
DAD WAS GONNA BE.
REUNIFIED WITH US.
THAT'S THE MEMORY THAT WAS
BROUGHT TO ME AS WE SEE.
THESE IMAGES ON TV AS I'M DOING
THIS INTERVIEW WITH THIS
REPORTER.
AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT I HAD
TUCKED [inaudible]
BACK.
BACK BACKPACK SOMETHING THAT YOU
DON'T WANT TO REMEMBER SOMETHING
THAT YOU DON'T CARE TO REMEMBER.
AND ALL I COULD REMEMBER IS JUST
CRYING MY LUNGS OFF NOT KNOWING
IF THAT WAS GOING.
TO B. RECONNECTING WITH US.
R. TELL YOU I HAD THIS
CONVERSATION THIS WEEK IN WITH
MY FATHER.
AS ARE PARENTS GET OLDER AND
THEY GET SICK.
BEGAN TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS IN GREATER
APPRECIATION OF THEIR TIME THAT
THEY'RE HERE WITH US.
AND I ASKED HIM A QUESTION I
SAID IF HE REMEMBERED.
THAT MOMENT BUT QUITE FRANKLY IT
WAS ABOUT ME WANTING TO TALK
ABOUT [inaudible]
I REMEMBER.
RIGHT BECAUSE OF COURSE HE'S
GONNA REMEMBER [inaudible]
BEING.
DETAINED AND NOT KNOWING HIS
FAITH OF COURSE HE WAS GONNA
REMEMBER BUT IT WAS MY WAY OF
WANTING TO TALK ABOUT HOW IT
MADE ME FEEL.
AND LET HIM KNOW HOW SCARY THAT
WAS [inaudible]
HOW FRIGHTENING [inaudible]
THE UNCERTAINTY.
AND QUITE FRANKLY JUST.
LOSING YOUR PARENT TO A
SITUATION THAT IS DEFINED.
BY A FENCE [inaudible]
A WALL.
THAT WE HEAR SO MUCH ABOUT NOT
NECESSARILY THINKING ABOUT
[inaudible]
THE LIVELIHOOD [inaudible]
SAFETY.
ASPECT OF KEEPING FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
AND THE EMOTIONAL.
IMPORTANCE OF ALL THAT I I
THOUGHT I'D RISE TO SHARE THAT
STORY WITH YOU BECAUSE THIS IS
[inaudible]
FRESH.
PROBABLY GOOD FOR ME TO TALK
ABOUT.
RIGHT MY DOCTOR WOULD PROBABLY
RECOMMEND.
THAT I'D LET THIS OUT
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
BUT I THINK THAT THERE'S A
LESSON TO BE LEARNED FROM ALL OF
THE STORIES WE HEARD HERE.
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR TODAY.
AND I TO SUPPORT AJ ARE FORTY
SIX AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA.
MR MACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
OUR EYES THE SUPPORT THIS A
RESOLUTION AS WELL.
I USUALLY DON'T GET UP TO SPEAK
ON I RESOLUTIONS I THINK THIS
MIGHT BE MY FIRST SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE BUT I
HADN'T SEEN ANY OTHER REPUBLICAN
STAND IN.
I WENT OUT THE MEMBER FOR RANCHO
CORDOVA SPOKE ABOUT A REAGAN
SPEECH IN HIS FINAL YEAR FINAL
SPEECH HE GAVE OUT OF THE OVAL
OFFICE ABOUT THE CITY ON A HILL.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE PASSAGES --
FROM A FROM REAGAN YOU KNOW
AMERICA HAS BEEN THIS BEACON OF
HOPE AND FREEDOM PEOPLE OF
COURSE WANT TO COME HERE BECAUSE
WE ARE AN AMAZING COUNTRY.
AND WE ARE AMAZING COUNTRY
BECAUSE WE ARE GOOD THERE'S THAT
LINE THAT SAYS THAT WE ARE GREAT
BECAUSE WE ARE GOOD.
AND WE SPEAK OF OF OF HUMAN
VALUES AND WHAT IS THAT WHAT OUR
HUMAN VALUES WILL.
OFFER SOME OF US IS THAT JUDEO
CHRISTIAN.
OF VALUE
AYE GREW UP ON A IN --
IN A HOME AND WENT TO CHURCH ON
SUNDAY MORNINGS WAS TO SING A
SONG.
JESUS LOVES THE LITTLE.
TOO DURAN.
ALL OF THE CHILDREN OF THE
WORLD.
RED AND YELLOW BLACK AND WHITE
THEY ARE PRECIOUS IN HIS SIGHT.
JESUS LOVES THE LITTLE CHILDREN
OF THE WORLD.
THAT'S WHO WE ARE AS A PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHO WE ARE AS AMERICANS
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT A SUPPORT
THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE RESOLUTION.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL MY COLLEAGUES WHO WHO GOT UP
AND TOLD PERSONAL STORIES AND I
ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK --
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE.
UP WHO REMINDS US.
BUT THIS ISN'T PARTISAN
NATIONAL.
I'M IT'S VERY PERSONAL ISSUED A
LOT OF US BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE A
PARTISAN ISSUE.
I DON'T WANT ANYONE TO FEEL LIKE
DESPITE MY PERSONAL FEELINGS
ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT THAT THIS
IS.
ANTI TRUMP THIS IS ANTI A POLICY
A ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY THAT
DOES NOT ALIGN ITSELF.
WITH OUR COUNTRY.
AND IN PRACTICE IS NOT FEASIBLE.
AS A WAY TO ENACT IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
I THINK EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF
THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS WHO SIGNED
ON AS CO AUTHORS TO THIS
RESOLUTION I'VE NEVER SEEN A
RESOLUTION ACTUALLY COME TO THE
FLOOR WITHOUT MANY [inaudible]
CO AUTHORS.
AND I DON'T WANNA PUT MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES IN A BAD
SPOT NOT GONNA OPEN --
THE ROLE FOR ADDITIONAL CO
AUTHORS.
BUT I HOPE THAT SOME OF YOU CAN.
FOLLOW THE LEAD.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM PALM SPRINGS
--
AN ADD ON TO MAKE THIS A TRULY
BIPARTISAN RESOLUTION.
BECAUSE IN REALITY THE VERY
SIMPLE FACT OF HAVING AN
IMMIGRATION POLICY THAT SAYS
ZERO TOLERANCE.
CUTS OFF A VERY LEGAL PRACTICE
AND THAT'S ONE OF PEOPLE FLEEING
FROM.
WAR TORN COUNTRIES.
COUNTRIES THAT OFTEN WE CREATED
THE SITUATION BY WHICH THEY HAVE
TO LEAVE.
IN ORDER SEEK ASYLUM HERE FOR
THEM IN THEIR CHILDREN.
A PRACTICE THAT HAS.
BEEN ACCEPTED FOR GENERATIONS.
AND A PULL PEOPLE EN IMAGEN PART
OF AMERICA.
WITHOUT SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM
THESE PARENTS WITHOUT
INCARCERATING THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER AND I
THINK WE CAN ONLY DO BETTER IF
WE DO IT TOGETHER.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
FAMOUS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THIS IS
AN H. A R. REQUIRES A ROLL CALL
VOTE.
CLAIRE PLUG ROLL-ON MEMBERS HER
WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHICH TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSE RURAL.
TELL ABOUT.
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE IS WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON S. B. NINE A ONE
WE ARE GOING TO THE CONCURRENCE
FILE.
THIS IS CONCURRENCE MEMBERS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY SEVEN IS AB TWO ONE SIX
CORPORATE.
SOME A BILL TO SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
ANOTHER SNACK RELATE TO
ELECTIONS.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAKE
AN OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
SIXTEEN ISBACK FOR CONCURRENCE
IN SAID AMENDMENTS WHERE --
THE AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL
NATURE IT'S A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE RETURN ENVELOPE
PROVIDED TO VOTE BY MAIL VOTERS
HAVE PREPAID POSTAGE INSURING
THE VOTING IS FREE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NIGHTMARE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
AMENDMENTS TO S. B. NINE A ONE
THIS IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE.
S. B. NIGHT A ONE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL
READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL NINE ALONG WITH
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN.
MR HOLD ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
OF THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
EXPRESS.
THE INTENT.
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE SURROUNDING THE INCREASING
THREAT OF WILDFIRES AND OTHER
CATASTROPHIC LOSSES WHICH
INVOLVE.
OUR ELECTRIC GRID.
WITH A TOTAL WITH THE GOAL OF
ENHANCING THE SAFETY.
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY OF
THE GRAD PROTECTING RATEPAYERS
AND STABILIZING THE UTILITIES.
ASSET THE AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED
AND THAT THE BILL GO OUT OF
PRINT.
COME BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE CONCURRENCE
FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY EIGHT THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY SIX CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN OF ACCOLADE TO
CONSERVATOR SHIPS.
MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
SIX IS BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
CONCURRENCE HAVE AFTER ON NON
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENT WAS MADE
IN THE SENATE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT.
NEEDLESS MAIENSCHEIN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK LOOKED AROUND.
OUR MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE A TIE THAT I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PASS AND RETAIN
A FILE ITEM.
THIRTY THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER RUBIO AN
ACCOLADE TO REAL PROPERTY
[inaudible]
MISS RUBIO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE NOW TO BRIEFLY
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN WHICH IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL AS A TECHNICAL MEASURE
WHICH CLEANS UP CODE SECTIONS
RELEVANT TO COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL TENANCY.
SOME SECTIONS OF THE CIVIL CODE
LUMP COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL
REAL ESTATE TOGETHER.
EVEN THOUGH THE UNDERLYING
INTENT OF THE LAW IS FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUAL RESIDENTIAL TENANTS
AND NOT THE COMPANIES IN THE
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS NATURE OF
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE.
OVER TIME AND WHERE IT MAKES
SENSE AN EFFORT IS BEING MADE TO
CLARIFY AND OR SEPARATE AREAS OF
LAW WHERE IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
TO TREAT COMMERCIAL RESIDENTIAL
TRANSACTIONS IN THE SAME MANNER.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THEY CAN [inaudible]
WITH THAT [inaudible]
CORPORAL.
IT IS HARD TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
THIRTY TWO AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT FIVE MISTER BERMAN THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
BERMAN AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
ELECTIONS THE CLEAR BEER TO SEE
THEIR UP SIGNIFICANTLY
[inaudible]
SURE BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES CYBER ATTACKS AND
DECEPTIVE VOTER MISINFORMATION
TACTICS PRESENT INCREASINGLY
SOPHISTICATED THREATS TO THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WOULD
IMPROVE VOTER FILE SECURITY IN
COMBAT VOTER MISINFORMATION.
FIRST THIS BILL WOULD DIRECT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS THAT DESCRIBE THE
BEST PRACTICES FOR THE STORAGE
AND SECURITY OF VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION.
AS WELL AS REQUIRE A PERSON OR
ENTITY WHO HAS RECEIVED ACCESS
TO VOTER INFORMATION TO DISCLOSE
ANY DATA BREACH. TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
SECOND AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
WOULD COMBAT DECEPTIVE VOTER
PRACTICES.
CURRENT LAW ONLY PROHIBITS THE
DISSEMINATION OF MISINFORMATION
REGARDING A VOTERS POLLING PLACE
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE LAW
TO ENCOMPASS THE INTENTIONAL
DISTRIBUTION OF FALSE
INFORMATION REGARDING THE TIME.
PLACE OR MANNER OF VOTING IT
WOULD INCLUDE THE DISTRIBUTION
OF SUCH AND IN.
FOR OF SUCH MISINFORMATION VIA
THE INTERNET I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
SEEM NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CORPS CORPORAL.
A MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI ABOUT I SIXTY
NINE KNOWS ONE ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY NINE KNOWS ONE ON THE
MEASURE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILEAND OVER.
THIRTY THREE ON RECONSIDERATION
ITEMS THIRTY EIGHT THROUGH.
FORTY WILL BE CONTINUE.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEMS FORTY ONE OF FORTY TO
PASS RETAIN.
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY THREE
AC ARE. TO FIVE TWO FIVE MISTER
COOLEY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWO FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY RELATIVES THE FOURTH OF
JULY [inaudible]
COOLEY.
GOOD AFTER COLLEAGUES ARE MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR.
TWO FIFTY TWO WHICH RECOGNIZE
JULY FOURTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS WAS NOTED BY
REVEREND BOB WELSH TO IN HIS
PRAYER.
THE TWO HUNDRED FORTY SECOND
ANNIVERSARY OF THE BIRTH.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THAT WAS PRECEDED ON JULY
SECOND.
SEVENTY SEVEN SIX BY THE COLONEL
CONGRESS VOTED IN FAVOR OF
INDEPENDENCE.
AND THEN ON JULY FOURTH.
THE DELEGATES OF THE RITUAL
THIRTEEN COLLEGE ADOPTED THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE.
AUTHORED BY THOMAS JEFFERSON.
FORMALLY ACKNOWLEDGING THE
DESIRE. FOR SELF GOVERNANCE OF
EARLY AMERICANS.
THEN AT GETTYSBURG AS I ALLUDED
TO A MOMENT AGO [inaudible]
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
MEMORIALIZE THIS NEW NATION ITS
MEANING.
REFERRING TO IT AS THE
DECORATION IN PRINCE AS THE TIME
WHICH OUR FATHERS FOUNDING
FATHERS.
BUT FOURTH UPON THIS CONTINENT A
NEW NATION.
THAT HAS SINCE INSPIRED MILLIONS
TO STRIVE FOR LIFE LIBERTY THE
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
THIS RESOLUTION ENCOURAGES
CALIFORNIANS. TO HONOR AND
RESPECT EXPRESSED GRATITUDE FOR
THESE BLESSINGS.
AND HONOR THOSE WHO SERVED IN
THE ARMED SERVICES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO'VE SUFFERED
INJURY OR MADE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE IN PURSUING AMERICAN
IDEALS.
IT IS VITAL THAT WE RECOGNIZE
AND CELEBRATE THE FOURTH.
IN ORDER TO PROMOTE GREATER ON
KNOWLEDGE OF THE HISTORY THE
FOUNDING FATHERS.
PRINCIPLES OF OUR PARTICIPER
DEMOCRACY.
AND TO DEMONSTRATE APPRECIATION
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE CONTINUED TO
FAN.
PURSUE A PROMOTE THESE IDEALS.
I ASKED THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN
FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION MISTER COOLEY IS
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL
ROLL-ON VERSUS IS CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON ACR.
TWO FIVE TWO IT'S CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE RATHER SEVENTY
FIVE CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE [inaudible]
I OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THAT RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
RETURN ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR LIMON
TO THE SENATE.
CLERK WILL KNOW.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM.
FORTY FOUR AC ARE TWO FIVE SEVEN
BY DR WEBER.
CLERK WILL READ SO WE CAN
CURRENT RESOLUTION THROUGH THE
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER WEBER
RELATIVE TO UNIFIED BOARDS
AWARENESS MONTH [inaudible]
DOCTOR WEBER.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU
ACR TWO FIFTY SEVEN WAS DECLARED
THE MONTH OF JULY.
AS URINE FIBROID AWARENESS
MONTH.
UN FIBROIDS ARE NONCANCEROUS A
BENIGN TUMORS THAT GROW FROM
MUSCULAR LAYERS OF THE UTERUS.
FIBROIDS OF THE MOST COMMON TYPE
OF TUMOR FOUND IN FEMALE
REPRODUCTIVE ORGANS.
THEY CAN VARY IN SIZE FROM
SOMETHING AS SMALL AS A BEING.
TO SOMETHING AS LARGE AS A
MELON.
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY FIVE
MILLION WOMEN IN THE UNITED
STATES AFFECTED BY URINE
FIBROIDS.
AND INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH LIKE
MOST.
CONTINUING HEALTH ISSUES
[inaudible]
AFRICAN AMERICANS.
DEVELOP FIBROID TUMORS MORE THAN
ANY OTHER GROUP THREE TIMES TO
FIVE TIMES MORE THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS.
ACTUALLY 90% OF ALL AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN WILL DEVELOP
UNION FIBROIDS BY THE AGE OF
FIFTY THE PAIN AND HEARTACHE
EXPERIENCED BY THOSE STRUGGLING
WITH YOUR IN FIVE WORDS OFTEN
FACED ALONE.
SINCE THEN SUCH AS HEAVY
BLEEDING AND CRAMPING IS AND
MOST IMPORTANT INFERTILITY
MISCARRIAGES.
ACCESS TO GOOD HEALTHCARE CAN
STRONGLY IMPACT EARLY DETECTION
SURGERY OPTIONS AND ACCESS TO
FERTILITY SUPPORT.
TODAY WE HAVE WITH US OF WOMEN
THAT WHILE INTRODUCED SOON WHO
HAVE MADE THIS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT PART OF THEIR AGENDA.
AND SO ONE YOUNG WOMAN BY THE
NAME OF THE KIA EDWARDS.
WROTE A STORY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH HER WOULD UNION
FIBROIDS.
AND HOW SHE IS A YOUNG WOMAN
GETTING MARRIED WAS EXCITED
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF
STARTING A FAMILY.
BUT YOU HAVE A DARK SECRET THAT
SHE DIDN'T SHARE.
AND THAT SHE HAD UNION FIBROIDS.
THAT MADE TOWARD HER DREAMS OF
EVER BEING A MOTHER.
FORTUNATELY FOR HER HEARD
UNIVERSITIES HER SORORITY.
THE NATIONAL SIR ROY DELTA SIGMA
THETA SORORITY.
BASICALLY TOOK THIS AS OF ONE OF
THE PILLARS OF A CATALYST AND
BEGIN TO FOCUS UPON THE ISSUE OF
URINE FIBROID TUMORS.
MY DAUGHTER WHOSE AN OBGYN WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES THEY
FACE.
AND IS OFTEN ATTRIBUTED BY THIS
YOUNG WOMAN WITH THE HELP TO BE
ABLE TO NOW THAT SHE COULD NOT
BE WITH US TODAY.
BECAUSE SHE IS VERY VERY
PREGNANT WITH HER SECOND CHILD.
SO THIS RESOLUTION TODAY TALKS
ABOUT THE NEED FOR GREATER
AWARENESS.
MORE EDUCATION A DISCUSSION OF
EARLY DETECTION.
OUR NEED TO RAISE FUNDS FOR
MINORITY RESEARCH.
TEND TO ENCOURAGE THE
PARTICIPATION OF WOMEN OF COLOR
IN A SAFE AND ETHICAL RESEARCH
TO DETERMINE WHY RATES ARE
HIGHER IN CERTAIN POPULATIONS.
TO ADDRESS THE LACK OF COVERAGE
AND COST FOR PATIENTS AND TO
RAISE FUNDS FOR RESEARCH.
WOMEN ARE SUFFERING SILENCE FROM
HIS CONDITION IN THIS TIME THAT
WE BEGIN TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
THEY'RE FROM HAPPEN TODAY TO
PRESENT TO YOU THIS RESOLUTION
THANK THE COORDINATED EFFORTS OF
DELTA SIGMA THETA SORORITY
SANDOVAL LET ME CHAPTER BUT NECK
FOR RECOGNIZE HOW IMPORTANT.
OF AN ISSUE THIS IS TWO WOMEN
WHO OFTEN FACE IT ALONE.
AND I WOULD ASK THAT PERSON A
ROLE BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER
[inaudible]
DOCTOR CHOI [inaudible]
MAYBE.
DOCTOR CHOI WILL PASS.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
SEEING AND HEARING.
NINE DOCTOR WEBER YOU WOULD LIKE
CO AUTHORS PLEASE RESOLUTION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS COOPER'S CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THEIR
SEVENTY TWO COAUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE.
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
DOCTOR WEBER BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR GUESTS INTRODUCTION YES I'M
VERY PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT TO
YOU OF THE DELTA SIGMA THETA
SORORITY FROM THE SAN DIEGO
CHAPTER.
NO THE INTERESTING THING THAT
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
AN I DIDN'T INITIALLY RECOGNIZE
IT UNTIL AFTER I WAS AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
IS THAT THERE ARE LOTS OF
SORORITIES AND FRATERNITIES AT
UNIVERSITIES.
AND THEIR VERY ACTIVE WHEN THEIR
UNDERGRADUATES.
THE UNIQUE THING ABOUT AFRICAN
AMERICANS IS THAT THEIR
SORORITIES AND FRATERNITIES ARE
ACTIVE WITH OTHER AFRICAN WHEN
THEIR UNDERGRADUATES BUT THERE
ARE MOST ACTIVE MOST ACTIVE
WITHIN THE GRADUATE CHAPTER.
SO DO YOU FIND THAT THEY'RE NOT
ARE IN COLLEGE.
THERE ARE MEMBERS WHO ARE
MEMBERS OF THE SORORITY FOR
FIFTY AND SIXTY YEARS.
VERY ACTIVE IN EVERY COMMUNITY
PROVIDING SCHOLARSHIPS RESEARCH
WORK HELP IN EVERY COMMUNITY AND
SO WHAT I DID WHEN WE BRING THEM
TO THE CAMP BUT TO THAT OF THE
CAPITAL.
IT IS NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY
JOINED A SORORITY WHEN THEY WON
UNDERGRADUATE.
IT IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
CONTINUED TO ISSUE OF SERVICE
AND SUPPORT ALL OF THEIR LIVES
AND THEY HAVE BECOME MAJOR
FORCES IN EVERY AFRICAN OF
COMMUNITY YOU CAN NAME.
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO UP
LIFT THAT COMMUNITY PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR THAT COMMUNITY HELP
YOUNG PEOPLE GET TO COLLEGE
ADDRESS ISSUES LIKE THE ONE WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS MORNING.
AT THE GRADUATE LEVEL I AM
PLEASED TO DAY THAT THE SAN
DIEGO ALUMNAE CHAPTER MY
DAUGHTER IS A DELTA SO THAT
MAKES ME EVEN MORE PROUD BECAUSE
THE FACT THAT SHE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY SISTERS.
SHE HAS THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF SISTERS AND THE DELTA SIGMA
THETA SORORITY IS THE LARGEST
SORORITY IN THE UNITED STATES IN
TERMS OF AFRICAN AMERICANS I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO HAVE WITH ME.
THE WOMEN WHO'VE COME UP WITH
THIS PRESENT.
A THETA SORORITY THE SENATE LET
ME CHAPTER THAT ONE THE PLANE
WITH ME THIS MORNING AND THEY'RE
HERE BUT IN THE AT THE CAPITOL
IN THE RENTS THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH
.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
FORTY FIVE AB. EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN COOPERATE.
SO WE GO EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT RELATE TO THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
FOR DECLARE THE OF CEDAR UP TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THINK YOU A. B.
EIGHTEEN NINETY SEVEN WOULD
APPROPRIATE NINETY TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY DOLLARS A
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD FOR THE PAYMENT OF AN
APPROVED CLAIM TO CEDRIC DAMIAN
TURNED OFF.
WHO AND WAS FOUND FACTUALLY
INNOCENT OF THE CRIME THAT HE
WAS CHARGED WITH INCARCERATED
FOR PASSING THIS BILL QUICKLY
WILL AND THE HARDSHIP TO HIT TO
THIS CLAIMANT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU IS BECAUSE ALSO
FLETCHER SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
FORMER SO.
DESERT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
TIRED OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUT OF VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME BUT I
SEVENTY KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE
URGENCY.
I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO ON THE BILL.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE IT FILE ITEM FORTY
SIX ACR TWO FIFTY SIX BY MS
REYES CORKERY.
ASSUMING CURRENT RESOLUTION TWO
FIFTY SIX WISELY MEMORY IS
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO ROSE USER
[inaudible]
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU ACR TWO
FIFTY SIX WHICH DECLARES JULY
TWENTY SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS BULLYING PREVENTION
DAY.
IN ADDITION IT DESIGNATES JULY
TWENTY SEVENTH AS ROSY STAY
RECOGNIZING THE LIFE.
A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD ROSALIE
ALVEOLAR.
MEMBERS BULLYING IN SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
ACCORDING TO THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES 28% OF U. S. STUDENTS
IN GRADES SIX THROUGH.
TWELVE AND 20% OF STUDENTS IN
GRADES NINE THROUGH.
TWELVE HAVE EXPERIENCED A
BOWLING.
IN ADDITION OVER 70% OF YOUNG
PEOPLE SAY THEY HAVE SEEN
BULLYING IN THEIR SCHOOLS.
TYPES OF BULLYING VERY AND
INCLUDE VERBAL SOCIAL AND AT
TIMES EVEN PHYSICAL BULLYING.
IT TAKES PLACE IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND ON SCHOOL GROUNDS WITH ONLY
2230% OF STUDENTS STUDENTS
NOTIFYING ADULTS ABOUT THE
BOWLING.
THIS CAN LEAD TO DECREASED
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT HEALTH
COMPLAINTS AND DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY.
IN THE CASE OF ROSALEE COPULA.
A TEENAGER IN YUCAIPA IT LED TO
HER FEELING THE ONLY WAY TO DEAL
WITH THE PAIN BULLYING BROUGHT
TO HER.
WAS TO TAKE HER OWN LIFE.
MEMBERS THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
ARE BULLIED EVERY YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA AND PART OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO EDUCATE.
EMPOWER AND PROTECT OUR CHILDREN
WHEN IT COMES TO ISSUES OF
BULLYING AND TO BE INVOLVED IN
THEIR LIVES TO ADDRESS
SITUATIONS.
BEFORE THEY BECOME DIRE.
ON BEHALF OF STUDENTS LIKE ROSY
AVI LA.
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE AFFECTED BY
SCHOOL BULLYING.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR
TWO FIFTY SIX RECOGNIZING
ROSIE'S DAY.
THANK YOU MISTRESS DOCTOR CHOI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK USE SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS TODAY.
AS A LIFELONG EDUCATOR FATHER
AND GRANDFATHER.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR TWO
FIFTY SIX AND I JOIN MY
DISTINGUISHED THE COLLIE X..
OF FROM SOME MONEY BEING ALL ARE
TO DECLARE JULY. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS A CALIFORNIA ARE
BOARDING.
PREVENTION DAY.
BULLYING IN OUR SCHOOLS TO AND
THE AND PRIVATE LIVES.
WE MUST.
TAKE [inaudible]
VERY SERIOUSLY.
AS I IT HAS OF VARIOUS
SIGNIFICANT.
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON ON THE
HEALTHY.
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR CHILDREN.
WITH THE ADVENT OF OUR SOCIAL
MEDIA.
WE HAVE SEEN AN ON INCREASE ARE
IMPORTING.
THAT CAN HAVE A CRIPPLING EFFECT
ON IN THE VICTIMS.
OF LAW THIS UP BEHAVIOR.
TIME AND AGAIN.
WE READ ABOUT THAT EPISODE SO OF
A SCHOOL ORDER [inaudible]
VIOLENCE.
THAT HAVE A THEIR ROOTS ARE IN
REPORTED A ACT OF LAW SCHOOL YA
DEPORTING.
AND THAT WE MUST A STANDOUT.
AGAINST IT.
IN FACT DOT THIS WEEKEND ON
SATURDAY.
JULY SEVENTH.
I AM PROUD TO BE YEAH.
PARTNERING WITH YEAH ORANGE
COUNTY KICKBOXING AND DUMB.
MIXED MARTIAL ARTS A STUDIO
HOSTING A FREE ANTI BOARDING
SEMINAR IN OUR BY. TO EDUCATE DE
JA COMMUNITY.
ABOUT KEYS ABOUT THIS ARE
IMPORTANT.
I WANNA ENCOURAGE EACH OF YOU TO
TAKE A THE PUBLIC STAND.
AGAINST A BOARDING AND THE
RESPECTFULLY URGE ON AYE VOTE ON
THIS SO IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
I DO THINK IT OF CHOI SEEING NO
EDITION ALL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
MS REYES WHO WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLARK WELL OF THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR A CO AUTHOR SIGNED
ACR TWO FIFTY SIX THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS [inaudible]
CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY FOUR CO AUTHORS ADDED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
RIGHT A PASSER RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS.
FORTY SEVEN FORTY EIGHT FORTY
NINE S. IS THE LAST ITEM WILL BE
TAKING UP ON SENATE THIRD
READING THIS IS SENATOR READING
FILE FILE ITEM.
FIFTY S. C. ARE ONE OH SEVEN
CLERK READ.
SO THE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
OH SEVEN BY SENATOR PELL
RELATIVES HIS ROLE MODEL
SERVICES.
MISTER FRAZIER EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
I PERCENT AS YOUR WINDOWS.
SEVEN A RESOLUTION THAT DECLARES
THE VITAL ROLE OF LEGACY HOMES
AND URGES REGIONAL CENTERS AND
OTHER AGENCIES TO BRING PUBLIC
AWARENESS. TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEGACY HOMES PROGRAM.
THE SEAL AGE PROGRAM ALLOWS A
FAMILY TO DONATE A HOME CONDO OR
OTHER SUCH DWELLINGS TO AN
EXPERIENCE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION.
WHOSE MISSION IS TO SERVE PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
A NON PROFIT HOUSING
ORGANIZATION WILL MENTION ON THE
PROPERTY AND GUARANTEE THAT THE
PERSON WITH THE DISABILITY MAY
LIVE IN THE HOME.
AS LONG AS HE OR SHE IS ABLE.
AND REGIONAL CENTER WILL PROVIDE
WILL ENSURE PROVISION OF
SERVICES IF APPROPRIATE.
SEAL IT PROVIDES A VITAL OPTION
FOR INTERESTED FAMILIES BY
ENCOURAGING THE GIFTING OF REAL
PROPERTY TO NONPROFIT HOUSING
COALITIONS.
ALL WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF
MAXIMUM CHOICE INDEPENDENCE AND
MEET THE NEEDS AND ASPIRATIONS
OF OF THE ADULTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THE PRIMARY GOALS OF STEEL EACH
ARE TO ASSIST INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES.
TO IDENTIFY THEIR FUTURE HOUSING
NEEDS AND PLAN FOR SUCCESSFUL
[inaudible]
TRANSITION.
HOUSING WORKSHOPS AND TRAINING
FOLLOW A STANDARD CURRICULUM
MODIFIED TO ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC
HOUSING MARKETS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS CRITICAL
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES OF
LIMITED INCOMES.
MANY ADULTS LIVE IN FAMILY HOMES
FOR AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
AND THEN UPON DEATH OR
DISABILITY OF THE SURVIVING
PARENT ARE FORCED TO MOVE OFTEN
TO FAMILY MEMBERS NOT FULLY
PREPARED. FOR THIS NEW
RESPONSIBILITY.
THIS MOVE INTERFERES WITH
ESTABLISH RELATIONSHIPS
COMMUNITY INTEGRATION ACCESS TO
SUPPORT ANOTHER VALUED OUTCOMES.
DONATING REAL ESTATE TO
CHARITIES IS NOT A NEWS PROCESS
PROSPECT TO WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US.
IS A PROGRAM DESIGNED TO HELP
FAMILIES PLAN FOR THEIR HOUSING
NEEDS OF THEIR FAMILY MEMBER
WITH A DISABILITY.
THE LEGACY HOMES PROJECT IS
UNIQUE IN THAT THE GOAL IS NOT
TO LIQUIDATE THE PROPERTY.
BUT TO KEEP IT IN THE HOUSING
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
PORTFOLIO TO RENT TO PERSONS
WITH INTELLECTUAL OR DOVER
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
SO FAR TWO AGENCIES FROM
LETTERMAN HOUSING ALLIANCE HAVE
RECEIVED LEGACY HOMES HOUSING
CONSORTIUM.
OF THE EAST BAY ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTIES.
AND NORTH BAY HOUSING COALITION
NAPA SOLANO CINEMA COUNTIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SCR WINDOW.
SEVEN THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE RESOLUTION MISTER FRAZIER
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS.
THE FIRST ROLE THE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON VERSUS CO AUTHORS ON S.
C. ARE ONE OF SEVEN THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE SEVENTY
THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS ANY MEMBER WAS REMOVED ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL NINE OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR CANNELLA AN I PLAYED
COUNTY NOT COUNTY ROADS.
CLUB CLUB IN THE ROLL-ON VERSUS
IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR THIS IS
CONSENT.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE NO DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES
I SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK READ THE REMAINING ITEMS
ON CONSENT SO THE BILL.
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE I SEVENTY
FOUR NO.
ZERO MEMBERS A COUPLE OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
MEMBERS AS YOUR BILLS APPEAR ON
THIRD READING OF THE SENATE
DAILY FILE PLEASE DESIGNATE A
FLOOR MANAGER TO PRESENT YOUR
BILLS.
ON THE SENATE FLOOR PLEASE
NOTIFY. TO THAT EFFECT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON.
AS WELL AS MR STONE YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR SPECIAL
[inaudible]
ANNOUNCEMENT.
MISTER GREEK MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS WE WERE US RESPECTFULLY
ASK ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
WEAR BOW TIE.
UPON A GERMAN TO PLEASE JOIN US
IN THE FRONT SO WE CAN TAKE OUR
PICTURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON.
I DON'T THINK WE NEED A WIDE
ANGLE FOR THAT PHOTO.
WE HAVE A FEW MEMBERS HOWEVER.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED IT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS WHERE IT ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
ORTEGA CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR
.
MEMBERS WE ARE DETERMINED TO
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO
[inaudible]
STATION FLOOR
MEMBERS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE DETERMINED TO MEMORY.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY IN ASSN WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF MISSUS
EMMA BELL MOORING.
THIS IS MORNING PASSED AWAY ON
SATURDAY JUNE TWENTY THIRD AT
THE AGE OF NINETY SHE WAS BORN
AND THE DEL YOU LOUISIANA.
AND MARCH OF TWENTY FOURTH
NINETEEN TWENTY A THEM IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE I'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN TO OF THE DAILY.
AND IT'S KNOWN FOR THE VIDALIA
ONIONS.
SHE WAS BAPTIZED IN THE
MISSISSIPPI RIVER.
IT YOU BECAME A MEMBER OF
YOUNG'S CHAPEL BAPTIST CHURCH AT
A VERY EARLY AGE.
YOU KNOW WHEN I READ ABOUT
MISSUS MORNING AND I KNEW HER AS
A VERY WARM AND CARING AND
GIVING WOMAN.
NOT SOMEBODY FAMOUS BUT SURELY
SOMEONE SOLID.
I OFTEN WONDERED WHAT SHE HER
LIFE WOULD HAVE BEEN LIKE IF
THERE HAD BEEN DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES IN AMERICA AT THE
TIME WHEN SHE WAS BORN.
AND DESPITE THE CHALLENGES YOU
FACE SHE REALLY WAS QUITE AN
ACCOMPLISHED WOMAN WITH
TREMENDOUS INTELLIGENCE.
SHE GRADUATED AS VALEDICTORIAN
OF HER PARRIS TRAINING HIGH
SCHOOL IN.
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE AND THEN
MATRICULATED TO GRAMBLING
COLLEGE IN GRAMM IN LOUISIANA.
UPDATES WE SEE YOU.
SHE HAD A VERY SUCCESSFUL
FRESHMAN YEAR BUT BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF HER FAMILY.
AND THE ILLNESS OF HER MOTHER.
SHE HAD TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL.
BUT SHE IMMEDIATELY INTERESTING
ENOUGH BECAME A KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER FOR ONE YEAR WORKING
WITH THE CHILDREN AT THE TIME.
IN NINETEEN FORTY LATE NINETEEN
FORTY SHE MOVED TO SAN DIEGO.
AND SHE WORKED AS AN ASSEMBLY
LINE FOR SOLAR AIRCRAFT OF
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE TO FIFTY NINE
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SIX SHE
MARRIED LOVE OF HER LIFE.
CURTIS MORNING SENIOR.
AND HE'S WELL KNOWN IN SAN
DIEGO.
BECAUSE MRS MORE IT OPENED I YOU
MISTER MORE OPEN THE CURTIS
MOORING INSURANCE AGENCY THAT
EXISTS TO THIS DAY.
THE ONLY BLACK INSURANCE AGENCY
THAT WAS IN SAN DIEGO ON NPR ON
AND ON ON IN THE IN SAN DIEGO IN
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
AND THAT STILL EXISTS TODAY HIS
SON STILL RUNS THE CURTIS
MOORING INSURANCE COMPANY FOR
THOSE WHO COULD NOT GET
INSURANCE AT THE TIME.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE SHE
VENTURED WORK A WIN TO WORK FOR
SAFE WAY IS ONE OF THE CLERKS.
AND SHE'S WORKED THERE UNTIL SHE
FINISHED HER DUTIES THERE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE NOW THE
INTERESTING THING IS THAT WITH
ALL THESE CHALLENGES AND RAISING
A FAMILY OF FIVE CHILDREN.
SHARE TREMENDOUS DESIRE TO STILL
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE HERSELF.
AND SHE WENT BACK TO SCHOOL AND
LEARN HOW TO DO TAXING.
TAXES AND BECAME A A TAXING --
TRAINER AND EVENTUALLY OPEN THEY
HIM A MOORING TAX SERVICE IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO SHE HAD THIS
BUSINESS A VERY SUCCESSFUL
BUSINESS WITH TWENTY YEARS TO
SHE CLOSE IT DOWN A TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO AND RETIRE.
SHE WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
SEVERAL CHURCHES INVENTION
BECAME VERY ACTIVE IN BETHEL
BAPTIST CHURCH.
AND SERVE THEIR FOR ABOUT
FIFTEEN YEARS WITHIN HER REAL
PASSION MOVED TO A AT THE BETHEL
A. M. E. CHURCH IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX WHICH IS THE OLDEST
BLACK CHURCH AND ACTUALLY THE
OLDEST CHURCH IN SAN DIEGO IT'S
OVER A HUNDRED YEARS OLD.
AND SHE WAS STREAMLINED ACTIVE
IN BETHEL WHERE SHE CHAIRED
UNCULTURED NUMEROUS ACTIVITIES
INCLUDING THEIR HUNDREDTH
ANNIVERSARY.
BUT SHE WAS IN CHARGE OF AN
RAISING LOTS OF MONEY FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE FOR PROGRAMS AT THE
CHURCH.
AND EVENTUALLY NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR WAS SELECTED AS A WOMAN OF
THE YEAR.
HER COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE WAS EXTENSIVE NUMEROUS
ORGANIZATIONS SHE WAS A LIFE
MEMBER OF THE IN DOUBLE ACP AND
SHE WAS A MEMBER VARIAS
DEMOCRATIC CLUBS.
AND SHE WAS A PART OF THE WORD
THE MAY FIT MATRONS OF THE ROOF
CHAPTER NUMBER ELEVEN THE ORDER
PIZZA EASTERN STARS.
SHE WAS A BOYCOTT BOY SCOUT DEN
MOTHER AND A PTA VOLUNTEERED
NUMEROUS SCHOOLS FOR HER
CHILDREN AND HER GRANDCHILDREN.
SHE PASSED AWAY AS I SAID ON THE
TWENTY THIRD AT THE AGE OF NINE
IT WAS INTERESTING THE ME
BECAUSE I WAS A WOMEN'S DAY
SPEAKER ON THE TWENTY FOURTH THE
DAY AFTER HER DEATH.
AND I CAME TO CHURCH LOOKING FOR
HER.
BECAUSE SHE WAS ALWAYS PRESENT
AT THAT CHURCH AND SHE WAS
ALWAYS PRESENT IN MY LIFE.
THERE WAS NOTHING THAT I EVER
DID THAT I DID NOT GET OF NOTE
OUR CAR OR EVEN A CONTRIBUTION
FROM IS THIS MORNING.
OF THIS VERY QUIET WOMAN WHO
WATCHED EVERYTHING THAT WAS
GOING ON AND WOULD SOON LITTLE
NOTES  COMMENTS HOW PROUD
SHE WAS HOW I REPRESENTED HER
WELL.
IT WAS ALWAYS INTERESTING TO ME
BECAUSE I ALWAYS IMAGINED WHAT
WOULD LIFE HAVE BEEN LIKE TO MRS
MORNING.
THIS WOMAN WHO GAVE SO MUCH WAS
SO SMART SO INTELLIGENT BELIVE
KEPT THROWING THINGS AT HER AND
YET AT THE SAME TIME SHE WAS
ABLE TO TAKE WHATEVER HAPPENED.
AND TURN IT INTO SOMETHING
WONDERFUL AND GREAT.
AND SO AS I STOOD AT THE CHURCH
THAT MORNING I LOOK TO THE LEFT
AND I DIDN'T SEEM TO THIS
MORNING.
AND I FOUND OUT SHE PASSED AWAY
THE NIGHT BEFORE.
AND A GREAT WOMAN AN AMAZING
WOMAN WHO LEFT NUMEROUS CHILDREN
HER FORCING HER FOUR CHILDREN
ARE STILL ALIVE.
AND ONE OF THEM PASSED AWAY HER
HUSBAND PASSED AWAY.
TO SHE WAS A FORCE TO BE
RECKONED WITH QUIET WOMAN STRONG
PERSISTENT AND DETERMINE IN
COMING OUT OF A SITUATION COSTLY
MADE SOMETHING GREAT.
AND WAS KNOWN AS ONE OF SAN
DIEGO STRONG THIS STRONG THIS
WOMEN TO HOLD UP THE COMMUNITY
OF SAN DIEGO WITH DIGNITY AND
GRACE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN MEMORY OF MRS EMMA
MOORING.
THANK YOU DOT AND WEBER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES THE DESI PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUEST RETURN A
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL WE
CONTINUE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GIBSON MOVES AND DOCTOR
CHEN SECONDS OF THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
JULY FIFTH.
AT TWELVE PM.
WE ARE TURNED